Democrats left with some truly terrible
options for 2024 President Biden has
reportedly told Barack Obama that he
intends to run for reelection despite
his poll numbers being in the dumps and
his presidency turning into a train
wreck for the country but his party may
have no other choice have you seen the
alternative
you haven't been to the Border
I and I haven't been to Europe and I
mean I don't I don't understand the
point that you're making I'm talking
about the significance of the passage of
time
right the significance of the passage of
time so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time I.E and this one has got to stay a
Washington Post writer bumping Kamala
Harris down on their 2024 Democratic
presidential contenders list putting her
behind Pete butterjudge okay let's start
with Joe Biden though how could a man
whose numbers are so low and so in the
tank believe that he deserves another
chance at running for president of the
United States given the fact that he
sold Barack Obama that he's going to run
again I mean this is a man who's got to
read some of the stuff about him that
he's you know cognitively weak and is
aptitude ain't what it used to be I
think anyone who actually does throw
their hat in the ring to run for
president has a confidence in themselves
that I certainly don't have and it's
unfathomable to me so there's one
there's that that he does think and he's
thought that he should be president for
all long time decades also I think
practically either he or his people know
that if he were to say he's not running
at this point that means they'll
absolutely get nothing done I think that
when they lose in the midterms that
there will be a real Reckoning and that
you might all of a sudden see a decision
about 2024 then I do wish I had been a
fly on the wall when Kamala Harris heard
this news because I think she's been
sitting there thinking are you kidding
me I'm sitting here trying to warm this
seat and I'm not going to be able to
have a go at it but also you let me tell
you some of these Senators who are up
for re-election in 2024 the Democrats
who would be on the ballot with Biden
that would be John tester of Montana Joe
manchin of West Virginia Sherrod Brown
of Ohio Bob Casey Pennsylvania Jackie
Rosen in Nevada Debbie staben on
Michigan and they would probably lose
all of those seats so there's a
practicality that's happening there the
last thing I would say is there's
something happening where this leak came
from an Obama Camp okay so Obama was
apparently told us by Biden Obama well I
told a couple of people those people go
out and don't give their names to the
Press but they leak this out and I think
it's because the Obama people don't want
Biden to run again and they're trying to
get it out there now so that it's out
there in the water do you think that the
Obama people want Kamala to run Geraldo
uh I don't know you know people that
live in that political world are
different than me I just think that if
not Biden I don't know who could run
against Trump well then I think Biden is
the only one who could beat Trump and I
also think that the the cognitive
decline is exaggerated by ideological
news coverage and I also think that we
exaggerate how badly Biden is doing
compared to Trump at the same point in
his presidency according to 538 Biden is
slightly ahead of trump at this point of
this President all right let me ask you
then about hispanic voters who were
disillusioned and disenchanted with Joe
Biden just 26 according to Quinnipiac
polls support Biden that is very
interesting it is devastating and I I
mentioned today in the last week I I
think that in my opinion Hispanics are
more interested in inflation and the
economy than they are issues like you
know uh the the Raging Fire over
immigration that's less relevant to most
Hispanic families I think they don't
like Biden because he's into bed with
the progressives and most Hispanics many
of them are conservatives but but you're
saying they're more concerned about food
and inflation but not the Border they're
concerned about the Border too the the
the Hispanics many of them are very
concerned about the illegal immigration
but you know what I want to go to you
Greg I want to talk about Kamala Harris
yes and I want I want to ask you to
listen to this it costs more money at
the pump she said this at a DNC meeting
last night or the night before so good
yeah it costs more money at the pump and
we have to deal with that we need to
acknowledge but also need to keep with
our program around making it easier to
get by day by day which means again
going back to child care she just said
that in the last 24 48 Hours geez this
generation's Hemingway I don't see how
you can that made total sense to me
everything she just said you know you
know what causes inflation Rising prices
you know uh she also do you know what
she did she went to Hollywood do you
know that she went to Hollywood the
reason why she went to Hollywood is
because she needed to find a group that
is even more unpopular than her to do
that so she appears a little bit more
confident that's why I hang around Dana
and you judge I appear taller to some
people because you people are are tiny
tiny people but that's what she's doing
she went to Hollywood because she needed
to be around people that just are just
worse than she is and then she kind of
looks okay Joe told Obama he was running
in 2024. he also told him he was Batman
that he could lift a car over his head
and then he could just hold his breath
underwater for three days but if you if
he ran um you got to think about this I
think that Gerald was writing part about
the exaggeration of some of the
cognitive declines however it's there
and in two years it's really going to be
there he's like a roll of toilet paper
every day you could see it getting less
and less there
he's the toilet paper roll of presidents
yeah we have guests okay I don't
understand yeah all right um you know
but there's one thing one thing I do
want to add to that when she defaulted
to child care I said to myself I am so
sick and tired of hearing about child
care we need to take care of child care
so he looked up the numbers and Sean you
might relate to this there are 330
million people in the United States
there are 46 million parents who have
children under the age of 12. so they
keep saying child care is the most
important thing but out of 330 million
46 million have kids under the age of
12. I'm sure most a lot of them don't
need the additional child care why do
they keep a defaulting to that because
it's it's a Switcheroo right don't don't
look at inflation and if your places are
going up with the gas pump if your
prices are going up the grocery store
we're going to help you with child care
it's an answer they can have to the to
the problems that people face I gotta
tell it I disagree with uh Geraldo in
the sense that Donald Trump is hoping
that Joe Biden runs again that is the
best matchup ever number one number two
with the Hispanics they do care about
inflation but they also care about the
CRT and the transgenderism that's being
taught to their kids in school I agree
that does not fit their values and so I
do think Joe Biden has worked a lifetime
to be president he's there he is not
going to leave the only way he leaves is
when the liberal media decides that he
has to go and if they turn on him and
start telling the truth about who he is
the liberal media will decide if he's in
or out and who knows what happens his
poll numbers are very low right now but
listen two and a half years is an
eternity in politics a lot of things can
change in that time frame and I I think
it's too early to to count him out all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else